what really drives me it's about
owning something building something from
nothing just your prior experiences and
getting up every day and fighting a good
fight and bringing some people along for
the ride
providing an opportunity for them that
i've been fortunate to have and
hopefully as the company grows and
prospers share in the wealth creation
that we collectively are building
together
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders this episode is about
breakfast but different type of
breakfast we're going to be talking
about the business of hospitality and
breakfast with somebody who really
embodies
the the nature and power of
entrepreneurship please meet david walsh
who currently serves as president and
ceo for peach tree foods inc
based in atlanta georgia peach tree
foods is the leading breakfast specialty
company in the commercial food service
and hospitality industry
david you are the definition of a serial
entrepreneur
and and i think that there's a nice play
on where's your cereal for breakfast now
yours you have a breakfast company but
but you're but you don't do breakfast
you do much you don't you don't do
cereal you do much more
than cereal and uh and i'm excited to
one day experience and the breakfast
solutions that you provide but but but
really we're talking about the
entrepreneurial journey behind it and
why you do what you do so david tell me
a little bit about who you are and how
do you find yourself you know being this
you know a multiple time ceo of a food
company
yeah well i mean as we spoke earlier uh
my background has traditionally been in
corporate right i i had a relatively
successful career in corporate america i
worked
for 10 years in in in the power tool
business with what i consider the finest
company in that industry
a great innovator great leader of
product development in dewalt
and then uh i ended up working for uh
newell rubbermaid after my 10 years in
blacky decker walt where i was
introduced to the to the commercial food
service and the food and beverage
business where i had
uh ceo responsibility for the
the
much admired rubbermaid brand in the
commercial food and beverage and
consumer food and beverage categories
and that was my first introduction to
food and beverage
however for me
uh
this
the thing that i love to do is is is to
accept the challenge of of building
something from scratch you know in
corporate you tend to inherit a company
you look after it for four or five years
two or three years four or five years
whatever then you pass it on to the next
person this journey for me with with
peachtree foods is all about building
something from scratch something
personal something built from nothing
and other than prior experience and
learn skills and hard work and
determination from the something from
the ground up which is what we've done
and i just find it so much more
fulfilling uh
to build something from scratch than to
inherit it you know
and uh the journey that we're currently
on or the current journey that i'm
currently on is mine you know i own it
completely albeit not exclusively i own
it completely and that's what drives me
that that challenge that motivation to
do something from nothing
and i love working for myself you know
uh and a small team of workmates and
trying to create something that can
provide an opportunity for people to
learn and to grow and ultimately prosper
as the company grows which i had the
opportunity to do during my corporate
years so that's what really drives me
it's about
owning something building something from
nothing just your prior experiences and
getting up every day and fighting a good
fight and bringing some people along for
the ride uh providing an opportunity for
them that i've been fortunate to have
and hopefully as the company grows and
prospers sharing the wealth creation
that we collectively are building
together so that is it drives me michael
i i love that and i i know it sounds so
authentic and genuine you know really
you know the core of what what
entrepreneurship is about it's about
fighting the good fighter just about
creating creating opportunity out of
thin air and then sharing that
opportunity with others bringing them
for the ride and then and and and i love
that fighting the good fight that's
that's just awesome yeah you know bring
me back to your introduction
to the food business yeah and
you know you're not coming from that
industry how do you perceive
how do you perceive it you know the
first time you you you meet it well i
mean ironically if i knew now what i
knew then i probably would have stayed
in the power to a business because
my wife and i are both foodies and we
love food and we're all things food
she's an awesome cook i'm not so much
but we love food and we love the whole
industry per se we love participating in
it now i'm quite enjoying working in it
but we're in a particularly narrow
segment of it right now as our company
we're in the we're in the hotel
hospitality segment as opposed to the
commercial food service but we have
plans new product development plans and
exciting plans for new products that'll
segue us into the food service
commercial food service business in the
next two to three years but um it's it's
it's a it's an it's a huge industry as
you can imagine right but it's really an
industry that's not that dynamic there
hasn't been a tremendous amount of
innovation in the take for instance our
breakfast segment i mean what's the last
innovative thing that's hit the
breakfast segment in the commercial food
service industry the waffle was invented
in the waffle iron patent goes back to
1850 something or other
waffles have been on the breakfast
buffet for 30 years in limited service
and full-service hotels uh across
america and indeed in in europe and the
the innovation the the only real
innovation after the waffles portion
control and the only reason innovation
that's come after that's been us you
know we we've taken a segment that's
waffles and pancakes and
automated the production of
pancakes to the point where
before covert it was a one-touch
operation for the guest jury covered we
developed our contactless module that we
both have so now the guest just has to
waive
wave for two pancakes you know so yeah
the ability for also smaller hotels that
don't have a full service kitchen like
with a range hud and exhaust fans and so
forth to be able to cook fresh
pancakes either front of house or back a
house is a wonderful innovation and it's
been
well received by the industry albeit
it's taking us 10 or 12 years to
to
get that technology
uh accepted by the industry if you will
you know we're we're kind of a post
covert of 14-year overnight success you
know it's a slow-moving industry these
the hospitality the limited service
hospitality segment is is is fairly slow
moving and hasn't been terribly dynamic
but we're hoping what's the what where's
what what are the bumps you know what's
what's sort of the pushback on on a lot
of these innovative ideas because it
sounds well your pain the picture you're
painting is that
you know it's it's purely beneficial for
any kitchen whether they have the races
or not to to integrate these ideas i
mean our patented technology is very
innovative and labor-saving and hygienic
and cool to touch and
atmospheric it's fun for guests to watch
their pancakes being made with just the
press of a button it's just there's a
this unfortunately quite a bit of
entrenched thinking in the industry you
know that
and it goes
i think some of it stems from
not a history of innovation
a lot of the food service industries
being consolidated by massive
corporations that are more about end to
end delivery at the best cost
than a as a best price as opposed to the
best overall solution you know if you
look at the food service industry of how
food gets to the tables of restaurants
and and hotels and
bars and kitchens across the u.s there's
only a handful of companies that provide
that conduit whilst there's many
companies supplying into these what we
call broadlanders or food service
suppliers
there's only a handful of those
companies that have consolidated that
industry
tremendously
and
i would i would argue that
because of a lack of competition there's
been a styming effect on innovation and
technology to the point where if it
doesn't fit into their model uh and
you're outside the box and it's new
you know they don't really have a
platform in their businesses to deliver
new technology and
innovation so it's come through uh
consolidation and then a little bit it
and i speak particularly now the limited
service hotel segment
uh a little bit of
state thinking
it's just you know they have been the
same thing for 30 years
and uh if it's not broken we're not you
know
right don't don't touch what ain't
broken right right yeah
now as you're thinking through just you
know some basic fundamental ideas you
know
myself and i guess so many of the
listeners are not coming from the from
the food or hospitality business what
are some basic fundamental things we
need to understand that consumers love
what is sort of the consumer behavior
around breakfasts and hotels that you've
learned i think that's a really
interesting question at least that i
want to know the answer to i i can tell
you i i tell you the the the number one
fundamental driver is it's free i can
tell you that
that's been that's been uh that's been
reconfirmed for a lot of these hotel
operators during the covet uh period
when covent hit our industry
particularly again the limited service
hotel segment okay when hulk coveted hit
that
that was an automatic shutdown
occupancies in the hotels dropped
dramatically but oh and but also the
ability to have people come in and work
for your breakfast or work the breakfast
service or clean the rooms or provide
from the house service disappeared so
our industry breakfast in in limited
service hotels disappeared for 18 months
and during that time there was a lot of
reflection a lot of consideration from
the brands as to whether or not we need
to come back and offer breakfast but i
can tell yeah the the guests and the
consumers voted with their feet
there was there was a resounding
disappointment when people turned up the
hotel to get an apple and an orange and
a yogurt bar and a juice bottle in a
brand bag at the front desk to say
that's your breakfast and you can see
that reflected through all the trip
advisor ratings and all the reviews that
you want to read and all the hotels and
all the travelers over the last 24
months they practically demanded the
breakfast bag and the number one driver
for it is it's free you know you can get
a lot of people a lot of people are
traveling with kids a lot of uh
sports teams are traveling you know if
you're not getting your breakfast that's
provided in your roommate you're you
know family of four or five top down to
ihop or mcdonald 40 or 50 or 60 bucks
that's included in your room right i
mean isn't that a wonderful incentive
for having breakfast to on offer in
hotels
and 100 percent i have to say though
yeah i i don't eat breakfast generally
except when i go to hotels because when
i go to a hotel it's free of course you
know i i it's not that i don't eat
breakfast it's against my my personal
diet to eat breakfast because i practice
intermittent fasting yet i make it a
point that whenever i'm in the hotel i'm
going to break my fast because i can
every you know you know you know the
expression there's no such thing as a
free lunch well everybody loves free
breakfast so sure and then of course
what's driving that is then yeah you
know there's competition amongst the
brands to upgrade their breakfast offer
you know
more hot items more fresh items
more nutritional specific items more
variety more on trend things like gluten
free options or you know all that sort
of stuff is
driving competition because
everybody has learned that the free
breakfast inside limited service hotels
ain't going away which is wonderful for
our business i mean we had a couple of
sleepless nights during the deep dark
days to cover thinking wow what if
breakfast never comes back in these
hotels what about if these hotels just
provide room and board and you know a
voucher to have something on ihop but i
can tell you it was resounding uh
support at guests and consumer level for
breakfast and the number one driver for
that in my humble opinion is the fact
that it's included
in your room right
now
as you're thinking through sort of your
own solutions to the hospitality space
and as you're growing them what is the
internal innovation cycle like for you
how do you how do you innovate and
continue to think through product
development in the food space yeah it's
a good question so fortunately i i had a
phenomenal uh
corporate upbringing you know as i
mentioned earlier for black black and
decade wall and dual rubber made
phenomenal consumer brands and that that
product development ethos and that
product development process and that
product development
bias in everything that you do that's
end user focus that's
you know looking at what end user needs
are unmet and how to create a solution
to deliver an unmet need
and when we look at the so our our small
space so we innovated with some
automatic a fully automated pancake
machine which as i mentioned we
introduced 12 years ago and
we're looking at broadening that now so
where else can we bring innovation and
automation and technology to this space
and
if you do a segment on what are the
typical items that are eaten at
breakfast it's it's it's no secret
that you'll find out that 40 percent of
breakfast consists of some type of egg
product so yeah if you think if you
think about egg what what what has been
innovative in in in eggs in terms of the
delivery of the egg from the pan to the
plate
practically nothing so so we've taken
some of our patented technology and see
if we can we can use that or adjust that
or
reform that to come up with something in
the egg space and
i'm pleased to say that we're very close
to being able to bring something to the
market that'll revolutionize the way
eggs are cooked in the in the hotel
space
working incredible working with elite
an unmentionable leading brand in the in
the industry collaboratively to to bring
some innovation to egg product
oh fantastic well i'm personally uh i'm
personally invested in a in a
plant-based egg solution for sunny-side
up so i may i may ask to make an
introduction later to this awesome
startup sure sure but it's also a crazy
market now
it is a crazy crazy market so i was just
on the phone today with our blenders in
the us making sure that supply of ag you
know coming back up off the latest flu
you know uh issue
uh is not going to impede our ability to
deliver we having some challenges in
europe right now um
uh with supply of ag particularly uh
cage-free cage-free barn-free uh eggs
um in short tight supply in europe right
now but uh it's a crazy crazy well of
course egg price i mean egg egg powder
is up over a hundred percent in cost in
the last wow
the last two months three months
so all the ingredients are rising
dramatically and it's not just the
ukraine uh russia issue it's it's it's
there's challenges throughout the world
on supply chain now ukraine is a big
food basket in the world and that's
driving putting pressure on pricing in
europe big time but you know we've got
milk powder up 75 percent we got egg
powder up 110 we got
wheat up 35
eggs are eggs eggs themselves are up 38
40 so
uh
this is another reason for having to
come up with innovative solutions on how
better to more efficiently use
ingredients and that's what we're we're
excited to be working on right now
now as you're
as you're sort of working in these
products how do you hardly garner
you know user feedback you have a few
users you you have the the hotel
obviously which is sort of the customer
but then you have your end users so it's
like b2b2c
and how do you get the customer feedback
for the products that you're delivering
is you're not necessarily meeting them
at the hotel yeah so so it's a good
question so it's a lot of family and
friends stuff to be honest with you and
it's a lot of small circle stuff and
it's a lot of stuff that we do
for instance we're we're researching
right now just to keep it out of the u.s
market we're researching some american
consumer behaviors uh remotely in japan
believe it or not
just to keep so there's no you know
we're testing certain products certain
pieces of equipment in american hotels
in japan uh just so we don't uh expose
any uh unregistered
or un patented yet technology here in
the us but
for developing concepts and developing
flavor profiles and developing that we
we use a broad network of family friends
and industry people that we we trust and
know have a good read on things so
yeah so tying back to sort of your
passion on creation
and entrepreneurship tie it all back for
me so sort of you know the david walsh
journey here
and where you're at today
where are you sort of your own journey
on your own path
yeah you know i would say you know just
getting started to be honest with you um
you know i i had a
i had a great career in corporate
25-year career corporal worked for
phenomenal companies
achieved
a level of success that was very
fulfilling but as i said earlier i
walked away i stepped out of the
corporate world
at the age of um
and and and and started my own company
from scratch and boots strapped with my
own money the money that i had built wow
over corp no external investors to start
with uh
and then when we came across the the the
popcake uh uh pancake technology uh we
set up a separate company that we got
some investors uh early stage family and
friends no institutional money small
money and we bootstrapped it you know we
bootstrapped the business we
bootstrapped the business and less than
a million dollars
uh at just dartmouth and uh
we worked it you know we take i took no
salary for a year and a half my partners
took wow salary for a year and a half
and we because we wanted to retain the
equity we didn't want to put it in front
of you know so we took those two those
two choices to be honest with you was
slower more controlled growth retain the
equity or go out and you know liquidate
yourself down to a smaller percentage
and be beholden to somebody well how
does that differ from corporate well
what have i done i haven't escaped
anything i've just changed you know from
corporate to private equity or venture
capital i mean i we so we took a slower
out we bootstrapped it we used our own
money we survived we prospered the
company's still fine and now we're
masters of our own destiny so that's
super fulfilling you know
i don't love that we don't answer to
anybody you know we we we
we barely have revolving lines of credit
in the business it's ridiculous we we've
been so lucky and so fortunate but we've
worked hard we've worked and it's taken
longer than it could have but at the end
of the day we're here and we own the
company and we don't have any you know
anyone to answer to other than our
customers other than to guests that
wanted an elevated experience at the
breakfast table in the morning
which is a nice way david your business
that is so awesome thank you so much for
this conversation and the inspiration i
i absolutely loved it and uh and i love
the mindset fighting the good fight
master of your own destiny
slower but with control and controlling
know what is your journey and how you
want it to be and and obviously work
extremely hard to just make it because
you have to work harder because you have
less resources and they have to have
more and you're not taking a salary for
a while and yeah but but really you know
that's i think that just
not taking the salary is a metaphor for
the many many sacrifices that you need
to make in choosing this path and so i
think that's important to keep in mind
david thank you very very much
pleasure
[Music]
you